- [Voiceover] In this video
we're going to be talking about
how you make a buffer.
There are two main situations
where you make a buffer,
and for lack of a better way to put it,
the first way is when you
know you want a buffer with a specific pH,
so you're making it on purpose
for a specific application,
and then the second time
that you might make a buffer,
especially in chemistry
class, is by accident,
which is to say that you're
doing something else,
you're probably a titration, for example,
and you just happen to have done
a reaction where it ends up with a buffer
in your solution.
So we're gonna talk a little bit about
both of those situations.
One equation that I'm going to refer to,
and I'm gonna assume that
you're already familiar with,
is the Henderson-Hasselbalch equation.
So that is pH
equals the pKa of the weak acid
plus the natural log
of our weak base,
which I will abbreviate as a minus,
divided by our weak acid concentration.
So if you're interested
in the derivation of this,
we won't go through that
in this particular video,
but we do have other
videos that talk about it.
So let's say we have
a specific reaction we wanna run at,
say, a pH of four.
So we wanna make a pH-four buffer.
In that case, we normally make
a mixture of a weak acid
plus a weak base,
and that weak base might either just be
a weak base like ammonia,
or it might be a salt
with the conjugate base
of our weak acid.
So an example would be
acetic acid,
CH3COOH,
and that's our weak acid,
and we might combine that in solution
with sodium acetate.
So sodium
plus CH3COO-minus.
And so I'm gonna draw this using the
molecular structures too,
because I think that makes
it a little bit easier to see
the relationship between
these two structures.
We have our acetic acid,
which has a CH3 group here,
and a carboxylic acid
group with the proton,
and this proton is acidic,
so it can donate that proton,
and then you get
the acetate.
So CH3COO-minus,
and then we have a sodium cation.
So if we combine our
acetate and our sodium
acetate salt and solution,
what we get is an equilibrium
between these two things,
and that's how we have something
that acts like a buffer.
We have our weak acid,
our weak acid being acetic acid,
and what our weak acid does is it,
let's see, let's do this
in a different color.
What our weak acid does is it soaks
up any added weak base.
So, sorry,
it soaks up any added strong base,
so hydroxide ions.
So it'll react with your hydroxide ions
and keep it from changing
the pH as drastically
as it would if the weak acid wasn't there.
And on the other side of our equilibrium,
we have our weak base,
which is the conjugate
base of our weak acid,
and what that does
is it soaks up
any added H-plus ions,
say, if you added some strong acid.
So that's one very common
scenario where you'll have a buffer.
You want a specific
buffer with a specific pH,
so you might use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
and you'll say, "Okay,
I want a pH of four,"
and then we'll look at
different salts and their pKa,
and then we'll adjust these concentrations
to get the pH that we want.
The second situation where
you might get a buffer,
and this one is also
really common in chemistry,
is by accident. (chuckles)
So what this means is you've made a buffer
because you combined a weak acid
with a strong base.
Or another way you can make a buffer,
which I will write in parentheses,
is you combine a weak base
with a strong acid.
And this is very common
in titrations.
So anytime you titrate a weak acid
or a weak base,
when you titrate it with a
strong base or a strong acid,
you end up making a buffer
for part of your titration.
So the example we'll go through here,
we're gonna start with the weak acid,
acetic acid,
like in our other example.
So we have this acetic acid, but this time
we're going to react
it with the strong base
sodium hydroxide.
So sodium-plus OH-minus
is how it dissociates.
And so what happens when you
react these two things together
is you get a neutralization reaction,
and this acidic proton,
so this acidic proton right
here on our acetic acid
can react with the hydroxide
and it will make H2O.
And then what that leaves us with here
is our acetate becomes,
sorry, our acetic acid becomes acetate.
And so you can see that if you react
a strong base with a weak acid,
which I will label,
if you react a weak
acid with a strong base,
you end up making the conjugate base
of your weak acid.
And so what this means is that
even if you didn't combine
your conjugate base with
your weak acid up front,
like in example one,
you actually make it in solution,
and so you can still end up making a base.
So the key situation where
you're going to see this
is in a titration.
To be more specific,
you'll see it in the buffer region.
And like I said earlier,
this occurs when,
when you're titrating
a weak acid or a weak base,
so a weak acid or base.
So you don't make a
buffer if you're titrating
a strong acid or a strong base.
But what this means is that whenever
you're doing this kind of reaction
where you might be making a buffer
as the reaction goes on,
that means we can use the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
right here
to do calculations about the pH
or the concentrations in our solution.
So these are the two main situations
where you'll have a buffer,
and in both of these situations
you'll probaby be using the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
to do different kinds of calculations.